in for your efforts we would just like
to announce to you all that we have
reached 200k so far and may Allah reward
you all immensely for your amazing
efforts but we still are in need of more
insh this is just an update and as you
know the Masid as it is is very small it
lacks space and capacity to really hold
the amount of brothers and sisters that
attend the lessons that we have in sh
bush in m and as you know the brothers
are striving to provide spiritual
physical and nutritional activities for
the Youth alhamdulillah the youth are
coming in Surplus amounts asking for
guidance and looking for ways and
methods to better themselves as Muslims
and as you all know this community is in
dire need of giving back and by way of
doing that we need a bigger place so we
ask you all to continue the support to
the Masid d sun in West London and we
ask Allah to bless your efforts and also
make it a means for you all to enter
into paradise and we also allow to you
know seal that
prayer so we ask all of you guys to
continue in donating as we do have a
target of two million and we hope that
you all inshallah don't lose hope and
you supplicate for us in your prayers so
that we can reach our Target and that at
the end of the day all of the deeds in
which you put forth to the building of a
Masjid will be written down on your
scales of Good Deeds as you know the
famous whosoever builds a mosque a mid
for Allah that Allah will build for him
a a place or house in Paradise so we ask
Allah you know to continue in you guys
benefiting likewise uh supplicating in
aiding the da may Allah bless you
all